your Nick who's never been can you break
down the process of what it's like when
you go to a strip club you walk in get
your little section they sit you down
get your drinks you have to get a drink
girls just like walk by and they come
and sit down in your lap and just lie to
you hi what are you guys doing what is
going on I love your beard oh my God and
you're just like oh thanks I'm letting
it grow like oh what do you do besides
this I'm going to school learning
business you're like that's great you're
too beautiful to work
how much does it cost for a lap dance
twenty dollars a song literally tell
them like don't dance in front of me
okay right here you know what they do
they [__] stand in front of you
little [__] dance they're just like
come on I'm gonna feel something maybe
they do this grind where they open their
legs up there's this pocket this pocket
where nothing's touching you're just
getting your legs rubbed on the side
you're like all right this time [__]
hurts actually
and then here's my money like an idiot